freshwater ecosystems are a lifeline to
our very existence
they support immense biodiversity
provide clean drinking water and are
powerful places where we can connect to
both nature and ourselves
I'm Dalal Hannah I'm a freshwater
ecologist and National Geographic
Explorer
the focus of my work is on the watershed
protection in Canada were immensely
privileged to have an incredible amount
of lakes rivers streams and wetlands
I spend a lot of time collecting samples
from streams rivers and lakes in rural
Quebec these ecosystems collect rain and
groundwater from surrounding landscapes
and move it across thousands of
kilometres bringing it to our towns our
cities and eventually all the way to the
ocean they're an integral part of the
world's hydrological cycle
and while some are protected from
development most are not which can put
them at risk that's a big deal
my work aims to uncover pathways to
ensure the continued health of these
priceless ecosystems
[Music]
the places I do research are beautiful
today we're in a lake system in north of
Ottawa my research assistant and I are
heading to an understudying water body
to document ecosystem health
what makes protecting watersheds
difficult is that they aren't something
you can easily see they're out of sight
and out of mind
a lot of indicators that tell us about
the health of these systems aren't
visible to the naked eye
we gather insects fish water soil and
plant samples analyzing them to check
for contamination nutrients abundance
and really focus on understanding how
our actions affect them doing lab work
in the field is one of the best parts of
my job right there in real-time I can
start to understand what's happening in
the water there's so much science can
help us to see a healthy watershed is a
large interconnected web of life
as a kid I loved canoeing it's what
inspired me to pursue this work it
taught me that to love something you
have to know it you have to spend time
with it
[Music]
with ripe area an organization that I
co-founded that brings youth on free
science expeditions we're working to
foster better connections between youth
water and science
there's something so magical seeing a
young person develop a new passion for
water these experiences could foster
relationships that last a lifetime
this is where conservation starts
[Music]
watersheds demand our respect and
attention
how we choose to care for them in the
coming years is a key challenge we must
all face together
to protect freshwater is to protect life
you